bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt français ce que est ce que
recours contre la préfecture de police
de paris vous semble justifiée alors
écoutez oui il est parfaitement
justifiée et on attend avec impatience
la décision qui va être donnée par le
conseil d'état dans la mesure où en fait
qu'est ce qu'on reproche on reproche à
aux services de police et notamment le
gouvernement de profiter d'une situation
dans laquelle au nom de de risque
sanitaire
en fait on va flics et racé et
surveiller toute la population française
est donc comme les pouvoirs qui sont par
rapport aux textes qui permettent en
fait aux polices de pouvoir déclencher
une surveillance généralisée de la
population
eh bien on considère qu'il est important
d'avoir des gardes fous et d'avoir des
précisions et notamment est ce que la
mesure est justifiée au regard du
problème de crise sanitaire et de fait
de surveiller toutes les personnes sans
que celle-ci en soit informé et aux non
en fait de la liberté de circuler la
liberté aussi de pouvoir de sa vie
privée on à une besoin aujourd'hui de
mesurer ce contrôle est de mettre des
garde-fous et pourtant un partout en
france des idéaux surveillance observe
déjà les faits et gestes de la
population en quoi est-ce que la
surveillance par drones serait pire en
terme de non respect des libertés dans
le divi duels vous avez raison il y
existe aujourd'hui des caméras mais
c'est dans le cadre de la
vidéosurveillance et ce n'est pas dans
le cadre de l'arrêté de 2015 qui était
sur l'utilisation de vol par des drones
dans l'espace aérien mais qui n'étaient
pas des fins de police et qui n'étaient
pas des fins de surveillance généralisée
parce que là on a en fait la mesure est
ce qu'elle est justifiée c'est en fait
la laque la question qui est posée dans
le cadre de ce recours
c est ce que c'est justifié pour le
risque sanitaire justifie qu'il une
surveillance généralisée de la
population
ces drones volent au dessus de jusqu'à
100 m ils ont des capteurs ils ont aussi
des haut-parleurs
lusage qui peut en être fait va très
très loin et surtout on ne veut pas une
banalisation de ce dispositif et ça
c'est aussi un point important parce que
l'on sait très bien que plutôt que de
les investissements qui ont été très
élevés pour les drones auraient pu être
mis dans le cadre de masques gratuits
qui auraient pu être mises à disposition
des citoyens là on a préféré les flics
et les surveiller est ce que cela est
justifié
et est-ce qu'on doit laisser à la police
la possibilité de voir si cette
justification est possible on leur donne
un pouvoir qui est quand même ici des
mesures et donc il faut des contrôles
mais aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
révèlerait qu'est ce qu'il révèle une
utilisation disproportionnée de ces
images ben au vol usage qui peut en être
fait normalement on devrait avoir un
flux de population là on a une
surveillance qui est mis en place soit
disant aussi pour permettre aussi aux
services de police de pouvoir se
déplacer d'aller contrôler on sait
également que ces drones comme par
hasard vont plus dans des quartiers
si vous voulez qui sont défavorisés les
quartiers populaires pour faire des
surveillances et on ne sait pas si c'est
simplement une surveillance sanitaire
et c'est justement ce point qui est
important et sur lequel on a besoin
d'avoir des informations ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui puisque cela
survol partout tout le temps et on sait
ce que c'est juste justifié non c'est
pas c'est pas nécessaire il ya d'autres
solutions
et donc il faut là dessus être
extrêmement prudent par rapport aux
autorisations qui sont donnés j'espère
que la justice qui est là pour protéger
aussi le citoyen sera si vous voulez
plus préventive que curative
merci beaucoup aux jeunes arras avocats
spécialisés et dans les nouvelles
technologies